hello and welcome to this video so wish
164 the opponent okay I'm glad you're
very a little bit don't need to play the
Banco every time what to do it try
something out him this line is new here
and liquids gambit declined keeps
irritating people then seems to be not
not all that bad do you go night BTW 76
lat bg7 assault a play that some basic
units been played by the world champion
more than once hmm what's going on here
and be fine looks quite shaky so I'm
going to just cover the phone with the
look think they go to these six
yeah looks like Ali legging the Queens
gambit declined just with I mean
structure wise but then pieces are
placed quite differently so what is he
going to do here 0 + f5 the play a5
myself might be five nope don't want
that why playing a five would be
interesting okay it doesn't do it h7 is
a tech so i probably have to play h6 and
now let's click prevent a four a five I
think that makes sense so now what is he
playing for you efore may be playing in
the center f1 okay try for a for my
bishop only six is indeed a little bit
awkwardly placed so I'm ready for night
of eight I am now is going 44 huh
yeah anyway
yeah I'm kind of say getting back to the
user that sets up it's kind of funny
okay if he goes eform i can take tyler
gphone okay as usual nobody look that
when I'm playing it somehow okay maybe
you just think that it doesn't matter
that he gives up isn't one Bishop might
be might be that it doesn't really make
a big difference so yeah he's got the
strong center
yeah museum possibly d5 coming up it's
tough to put pressure on the center
hmm yeah it was definitely right giving
up the bishop didn't really matter all
that much Gupta 70s got d5
oh very uncomfortable playing this
mostly to come at seven so that maybe i
can i can move from my Bishop to g4
trying to trade but he's got to know it
doesn't have that try to trade and we
can you spawn idea for a little bit of
possible if you're taking with a cheap
on here or what okay now of course but I
don't have to take now on d5 can play
this for example 95 don't know i'll be
56 of course we should be second let's
just keep this
yeah so I'm okay again unless I'm
blundering stuff that's possible but
position is ok now maybe I can do
something on the D file time-wise them
but time wise it will be critical they
threatened on g6 I could have supplied
hoopty too by the way anyway ok I can I
can still play anyone in this doesn't
really make a big difference we should
be 3m with one day exchange maybe I
still get a second chance he says he I
mean this position is a bit tangled up
here
c8 next rook t1m is what i want to do i
also had 95 I'm keep missing things here
95 would have already ended good thing
you can still do it
free you just collapsing one light takes
also wins check this is kind of okay
right check check on my head on the
clock check check check check my crew
create like forfeits on time yeah I
certainly warhead and certainly run some
trouble here or to the Nemesis view yeah
this is a funny like an a6 but it's not
so bad yeah if item just if I does not
take on d5
that one's usually does I can take this
is an interesting situation FB five is
move now possible supported by a six
yeah just compared with the semi slavia
where you play c6 and the board Winnick
they've got a 60 now why do I shouldn't
this be possible quite interesting and
in the exchange well a success hmm kind
of a move that might be useful but one
thing is clear why does not want to have
the knight on f3 and every single
instance and they play it like that i
think on queen bee three you can even do
that and counter I mean potentially
counter attacking him okay I mean I
think he played it really well like here
let that works oh I just have to Bishop
takes h2 oh my god yeah okay it's early
in the morning but still I should have
seen that and he is still just yeah you
know what I can do it you can take and
then I check as king g 3g five is
terrible ah okay yeah now we addressed
it yeah I wasn't so afraid of that
because I felt pleased if you give me
this Bishop I should be okay but it
didn't feel all that great the engine
like my position queen bee 60 ok ok I
want to take this and no hooks establish
disliked creepy six I was always afraid
that this this point centers going to
just yeah roll forward
yeah I was ok yeah yeah I was supposed
bit it was a bit afraid yeah and now I
fell them okay really am now in hand the
engine confirms that I'm fine some
alternatives but this is looking good
[Music]
and I t5 also was interesting why is
that so great I mean I probably this is
just bad him that is bad like it's
completely dominating on the dark
squares i plated it the claim that we
should be three was already possible
here and 95 one move earlier some bit of
a sloppy game but it didn't didn't hurt
them my position all that much think
that I miss ok guys thanks for watching